Some of the reasons
that it was rejected.
People just didn't buy my vision.
People didn't think that
they can execute on that.
People thought that they saw companies
that wanted to do the same thing.
But they failed.
So they assume that I'm
going to fail as well.
People thought the market is not real or
people thought the market is too
small or people thought the market is
too big and there's no chance that
the small fish like me would be
able to take a decent cut of it.
People thought that we don't have
the necessary skills in the team.
And people thought that we just
don't know what we're doing.
So we were rejected so many times,
many more times than we were accepted.